première décision c'est rétablir la
sécurité à besançon donc on va revenir
sur le programme actuel c'est-à-dire une
armement de la police au niveau létale
est aussi 20% de hausse des policiers
municipaux supplémentaires et bien
d'autres principal atout c'est la
nouveauté
voilà c'est la nouveauté je veux dire on
peut pas nous taxer d'avoir déjà été
soit en opposition ou soient en majorité
ce que tous mes autres concurrents ont
été je sais pas si j'en ai voilà bon
principal handicap mais c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être le manque de moyens dans
la campagne que ce soit le moins le
manque de moyens financiers c'est vrai
que rivaliser avec des grosse cavalerie
qui met je me permets de le dire cent
mille cent vingt mille euros sur la
table
nous on fait tout avec eux rien mais
c'est aussi une vertu eh bien écoutez
moi je suis triste pour lui voilà je
suis triste pour lui parce que bon jean
louis fousseret même si ç'a toujours été
un opposant politique
il ay l'a fait il a fait du travail on
sent que c'est quelqu'un qui connaisse
et sa ville et qui l'aimé et je trouve
que bon la fin est un peu discutable